to say there have been irregularities in
the funding of Donald Trump's campaign
would sort of be a major understatement
I told you yesterday how in order to
funnel more money back into his own
businesses he tripled the rent at Trump
Tower once it was his campaign donors
that started paying for the rental space
of that office we have now learned that
Donald Trump used his campaign funds to
buy thousands and thousands of copies of
his own book at retail cost again
diverting donor money back into his
pockets while artificially boosting
sales figures of the book the campaign
paid barnes and noble fifty-five
thousand dollars on May tenth according
to a filing with the Federal Election
Commission which is roughly 3,500 copies
of the hardcover version of his book
crippled America how to make America
great again or 5,000 copies of the
renamed paperback release great again
how to fix our crippled America what's
his explanation Trump's campaign is
saying okay we were giving those away at
the Republican National Convention
something that we have to do so we
bought them and then they were being
given away and that's that and it is
true that delegates who went to the
Republican convention in Cleveland last
month were given canvas tote bags they
had the Trump slogan on them they had a
copy of crippled America they had
Kleenex make America great again cops
hats and t-shirts and plastic fetus
figurines now I I don't want to lose the
thread about the books but I do want to
just show you if you're watching what
the plastic fetus figurines looked like
we have a picture of that that we're
showing here and it was amazing is that
anti-abortion activists actually use
these fetus figurines they say when you
test positive for pregnancy that's what
you have inside you essentially a fully
formed fetus of course no actual science
confirms that because it's completely
bogus and false so that that's an aside
those are the now that we've dealt with
the plastic fetus figurines that were
had
that out of the rnc we'll get back to
the Trump book stuff uh the RNC was
asked is it true that trumps campaign
had to do this the RNC has not comment
on that commented on that uh there have
been others asked for explanations on
this and the most interesting comment
comes from the campaign Legal Center
which is that in order for this to be
legal Trump would have to at minimum
forgo accepting the royalties for sales
on the books in other words from the
purchase price some portion of that goes
back to trump is the author the royalty
he would have to forgo that we don't
know if he's done that they've been
asked they haven't said uh but big
picture of course you were still doing
this in a way that increases the number
of books sold which increases your your
prominence and notoriety it is yet
another way Louis and we've talked about
uh the the the way in which he has
helped his sons vineyard by running
campaign events there this is all about
enriching the Donald Trump family yeah
enriching the Donald Trump brand it's uh
if I were Donald Trump's campaign
manager and I think I would do
tremendously well accordin up the the
bombs he's had that thus far trust me um
I would just say that this is a bad idea
yeah this is just not something we need
to do we can give away other things uh
this is bad optics why do we need to do
this at all no one gives a crap about
your book Donald at the same time one of
the funniest parts about Donald Trump
self-enrichment schemes is that they're
almost comparatively small time in the
grand scheme of things right for a
billionaire supposedly he kind of isn't
thinking that big with these schemes yet
you jack up your rent to pay yourself a
little more the campaign office you buy
your own books you do some events at
your kids vineyard it's almost like a
small-time grifter carrying out it's
like a billionaire who's carrying out
the ideas you would more associate with
a small-time grifter and maybe that's
kind of what Trump is yeah well maybe he
is uh kind of one of these guys who uh
does a million different sheisty little
Fiat he's got a lot going on and and it
all adds up he was buying hundreds of
dollars of Trump bottled water for the
campaign as well uh so there's that
little bit